c'est ce qu'on appelle un phénomène
musical les groupes français de house
music sont plus recherchés à l'étranger
les plus connus d'entre eux comme daft
punk air ou stardust sont tous des
français ils vendent plus facilement
plus d'un million d'exemplaires de leurs
disques parmi ces dj célèbre puis à
emmanuel luneau et didier dawn ont suivi
à new york ce de cassius depuis quelques
mois il ya quelque chose de mes français
dans les rues de new york
après l'europe les etats-unis découvrent
à leur tour la french touch daft punk
air dimitri from paris ce soir c'est
cassius qui officie où l'une des
meilleures discothèque de la ville
ces mots sont encore peu connus du grand
public en france à l'étranger en
revanche les night clubs ne jure plus
que par les dj français daft punk un
million cent mille albums vendus à
l'étranger
r un album classé aux etats unis parmi
les dix meilleurs de l'année et tarbes
est que cette boutique chez diffuse à
longueur de journée c'est un million
deux cent mille titres soit 50% des
ventes plus dernier céline dion
on dirait qu'il ya toujours quelque
chose de nouveau qui sort de certains
albums je ne savais même pas qu'ils
essaient français et ils sont vraiment
très connu par ici votre boutique même
succès 1999 l'album de cassius s'est
classé 4e meilleure vente alors des
français et champion du monde différence
entre son français le sang anglais ou
américains il est plus funky les basses
sont plus présentés il ya plus de disco
c'est vraiment plus classe plus élégant
et c'est ça qui fait bouger
effectivement ça marche blasés les
budgets français
alors justin new york londres berlin les
influences de cette musique sont
forcément cosmopolite la french touch
peut-elle rester french encore longtemps
musique la base de cette musique c'est
d'être justement globale de ce vivier
français de nouveaux groupes sortent
presque toutes les semaines il n'est
plus belles matières premières que la
france puisse exporter